Mars has always been a second virtual home for humans,
But with the start of a plan to send people and colonize the Red Planet as early as next decade
Do you have what it takes to get to and live on Mars?
The first challenge you get is during the launch phase
High levels of acceleration may destroy the body
At about 9g most people lose consciousness because of anemia in the brain
As a result, human missions were limited to 3g
Or three times the force of gravity on earth
Which astronauts are trained to deal with
So if you can survive in the first few minutes without a missile system failure or stress reduction problems
Your focus is to protect yourself from the sun's rays
Leave the atmosphere and protect us
Increase your risk of cancer and destroy your central nervous system
You definitely want to go when the Earth is in alignment with Mars
Which occurs every two years
You will usually spend 150 days on your way to the trip
You may also wish to consider removing the bitterness and excess of a long extended journey
Because it can protect those members from explosion due to pressure changes.
Gmsk now adapts to the smaller gravity
You will now feel the side effects of weight loss
The fluids of your body will turn up all over the body,
Causing you headaches and temporary blindness
You can also expect a slow digestive system because your body adjusts itself
Because of the limited space, she may wear the same clothes for a long time
Even astronauts on the ISS dressed in their underwear for up to a week
This explains why astronauts are more susceptible to urinary tract infection
A study by NASA showed that pioneers lose an estimated amount
With more than 1% of bone mineral density per month
If you want to work about two hours a day
As astronauts do aboard the International Space Station, you will have a better chance to face this
Sex may also help, but it may consist a bit tricky
According to Newton's Third Law, each movement of the couple will confront the other
Q2SUIT: A space suit designed for two people which in turn can be compressed like a sleeping bag
It is forbidden to push one of the other two away
Once you land on Mars, you will begin to notice the differences between
Your new home and planet
Mars is farther from the sun, so the temperature ranges from -140 ° to 30 °
But that does not mean you can walk outside on warmer days
The Earth's atmosphere is 100 times more intense than Mars
So you'll stay protected from the sun's rays
This means that you may have to get used to living in an underground habitat
When you leave your home, you may wear sweating clothes
To protect your blood from boiling
Otherwise, your members will be free of atmospheric pressure
The food will be dry, ice-cold and packed with nutritional requirements that taste good though
You will have a thin fabric, so your botanist can grow fresh fruits, vegetables and vegetables
You'll get to see vegetables grow naturally outside
Or that people or animals are moving around you
Using NASA's Mars simulation research, it is likely to live in a habitat
Of small size, 900 square feet flat with a bunch of other sage
You may need to stand together with people, or it may be difficult to find people to mate with
And the development of a colony
Genetic diversity is an important part of maintaining large healthy collections
The lack of enough people for mating often leads to breeding or internal reproduction
Studies have shown that it results in the loss of more than 80% of the diversity of the gene
Causing your small community risk of extinction through disease
An old study suggested that the new colony may need about 150 people
To maintain the stability of genetic diversity, but more recent studies suggested that the figure
Between 10,000 and 40,000 people we need
If this is true, you may have to wait a few months for more sage to arrive
Before they mate
Even with all these risks, you will have to pass
Test the space agency for pioneers before going
Which will be mentally and physically strict, but if you are accepted
Do you want to go?
If you want to learn more about how life will look on Mars
are you going? Check the next section by clicking on the screen
Or link in the Description box
Subscribe to more weekly sections every Tuesday Translation: Team translate @autrjim